la vie trépidante que nous menons dans
notre société moderne et cause pour
beaucoup de ce mal du siècle que nous
appelons le surmenage 1966 le surmenage
professionnel est déjà considéré comme
le mal du siècle
aujourd'hui on l'appelle le burn out ou
le syndrome d'épuisement professionnel
en france c'est dans les années 90 que
le personnel aidant travailleurs sociaux
enseignants médecins commencent à parler
ouvertement dans les médias du burn out
indiscutablement j'ai fait un épisode
d'épuisement professionnel
cela s'est traduit comment bien le avoir
peur de dénoncer une mauvaise nouvelle
en particulier si le pronostic était
très semblable à la sensation que
j'étais plus bon à rien que je n'ai ma
place le début la perte de confiance en
soi mais aussi fatigue et stress font
partie des symptômes du burn out et à
partir des années 2000 la parole se
libère chez tous les actifs paul lui à
26 ans il évolue dans les métiers de la
communication
son travail l'a épuisé il vient de se
faire interner avec la rade pour l'agglo
pied c'était le travail ou moins un
épuisement professionnel qui pousse
aussi parfois des situations extrêmes
j'avais plus d'identité jeu je voulais
mourir je n'existais plus comme il
m'avait tué manière sur le plan salariés
ce jour là et bien
j'étais morte si les cas de burn out
semblent se multiplier en france les
statistiques sur le sujet reste flou le
cabinet technologia spécialisé dans la
prévention des risques estime à 3,2
millions le nombre de français au bord
du burn out contre trente mille pour
l'institut national de veille sanitaire
une fourchette large qui en dit long sur
la difficulté de mesurer les troubles
psychiques
prenons le temps de définir tous les
tableaux psychique et pas que le bernard
sans quoi nous allons aboutir aux mêmes
concepts poubelles que pour le
harcèlement aujourd'hui le burn out ce
n'est toujours pas reconnue comme une
maladie professionnelle
un combat que mène pourtant de nombreux
parlementaires depuis quelques années en
2015 le député ps benoît hamon déposé
trois amendements à l'assemblée
aujourd'hui vous fait une dépression
liée à votre travail c'est l'assurance
maladie qui paye je souhaite qu'une
dépression liée au travail soit reconnu
comme lié au travail que ce soit la
branche accidents du travail qui paye
quelles conséquences à cela
inciter les entreprises à modifier leur
organisation du travail de façon à
prévenir ces infections que si j les
propositions de benoît hamon resteront
vaines
tout comme celle des députés la france
en soumises
en février 2018 l'assemblée nationale
rejetait leur proposition de loi pour la
reconnaissance du burn out comme maladie
professionnelle
[Musique]